Let's define a trivial
Gradle project to work with.
This one doesn't compile or
build anything, it just tells a joke.
And we can use it to do all the normal
gradle stuff we're used to, like,
we can get all the tasks that this can
do, and we can run our tell-joke task.
Awesome.
Everything's working.
Now, let's try importing this
project into Android Studio.
So, here's the Android Studio
splash screen.
What we want is this import
project Eclipse ADT, Gradle, etc.
And it tells us to go select our
build.gradle file or some other options.
Let's go find it.
All right, here is our super,
simple build.gradle file,
it's the only thing in this directory.
Android Studio will pop up a dialogue
asking you if you want to use
the Gradle wrapper.
Android Studio always uses the wrapper,
and always uses the Gradle build daemon.
We'll go ahead and
let Android Studio set up the daemon.
When Android Studio first opens,
you might not see anything interesting.
To see what's going on with your
project, just open up the projects tab.
You still won't see anything for
the moment since the project pane is
configured to display only the files
that are relevant for an Android build.
Fix that by clicking on the Android
drop down and selecting Project.
Now, if we expand out this directory,
we can see a whole slew of files that
Android Studio has already created for
us.
Note, that you can see
your build.gradle file,
as well as the gradle W wrapper scripts.
As well as a bunch of other stuff
that was added by Android Studio.
There are several ways to run
Gradle tasks from Android Studio.
The first is the terminal
down at the bottom left.
Here we can do exactly the same stuff we
were doing from outside Android Studio.
Note that the first time you use the
gradle wrapper created by Android Studio
you may need to add execution permission
to the wrapper script like so.
So, now we can get our
task list like normal.
There we go.
And we can run our tell joke task again.
Awesome.
So, we can
do everything we could do from a command
line from inside Android Studio as well.
There's also an easier way to
Gradle tasks from Android Studio.
And that's by opening up the Gradle
pane on the right of the window.
If we open up the Gradle
scratch directory and
we open up the other tasks,
we find our tell joke task.
We can double click to run it.
Excellent, our task is still working.
Let's open up our build.gradle file.
Let's try adding a second
jug-towing task to our project.
In order to get Android Studio
to recognize our second task,
we need to hit these little
circular arrows again.
There we go, here's our new task, and
we can run it just like the other one.
A moment ago,
we just had to build that Gradle file.
And now we've got a directory totally
full of obscure files and directories.
Unfortunately, IDEs tend to do that.
Let's take a look at these various files
and figure out why they're all there.
The .gradle directory is where
Gradle stores information for
incremental build support.
So, that's your tasks inputs and
outputs, stuff like that.
The .idea directory is where Android
Studio stores its model of your project.
The build directory is where your build
outputs go, if this build generated any.
For now, it's just holding onto
some information related to the
synchronization between Gradle's project
model and Android Studios project model.
Finally, you know the Gradle directory.
That's where the wrapper JAR and
the wrapper properties are stored.
In the root folder,
we have our build.Gradle file
that we originally added.
We also have this .iml file,
which is again part of
Android Studio's project model.
Finally, we have the two wrapper scripts
and then this local .properties file.
This is how gradle can figure out where
the Android sdk is on your machine.